[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle Jane et moi
John carte de crédit et puis un
certificat de
mariage on est marié croire qu'on est
marié il nous avait pas parlé du mariage
avant le dernier tien une vie technique
du KGB on Mo l'atention en
couple
[Applaudissements]
c'est très
romantique quel métier
exercez-vous on est développeur logiciel
administrer une simple dose pas de
victime merde si la compagnie ne vous
avait jamais couplé vous seriez
compatible tu ass sur un hab que je
viens de construire pour toi c'est moi
qui a allumé le feu et c'est moi qui
abris manger feu oh non
possible le boulot la vie l'argent
l'amour tout ça ça fait partie du même
projet tu as dit que tu
m'aimais toi aussi tu l'as
dit on croyait qu'on allait
crever tu le pensais pas c'est la
vérité c'est
cool
ti-toi
pitié
[Musique]
désolé c'est juste un travail ce n'est
pas une question de vie ou de mort
ok ça va
[Musique]
mieux